et l'on retrouve tout à l'heure et nous
on se met à l'autre bout de la vie d'une
entreprise à ses tout débuts
c'est là que se joue que se joue toute
sa pérennité et pour assurer sa
longévité différents dispositifs
d'accompagnement existent la chambre des
métiers nous explique lesquels avec
sylvie mérigeau des halles quel type
d'entreprise peut bénéficier de votre
aide
alors de notre aide au niveau de la
chambre de métiers nous on m'a traitée
tout ce qui est en lien avec l'artisanat
donc ce qui veut dire qu'on va le
regroupés en quatre grandes familles on
peut même en rajouter une cinquième
donc on va voir toutes les activités du
bâtiment c'est à dire l'électricien le
plombier le plat kiss le peintre le
coureur ça peut être également les
métiers de service donc une
esthéticienne une coiffeuse par exemple
ça va être ce qu'on appelle nous les
métiers de bouche donc le boucher le
boulanger le charcutier le poissonnier
le glacier et il nous avons également
donc les activités de production
c'est-à-dire dès lors qu'on fait des
petites séries qu'on n'est pas sur des
pièces uniques donc la serrurerie la
métallerie
est-ce que je vous indiquais c'est que
on peut même en ajouter une cinquième et
ça me permet de faire le lien avec votre
annonce est le souffleur de verre de
tout à l'heure ce qu'on appelle les
métiers d'art donc en effet on peut être
dans cette catégorie là on peut avoir
les des luthiers par exemple les
fabricants de bijoux
donc si fico niveau de l'artisanat nous
allons couvrir l'ensemble de ces grandes
familles on va dire d'une certaine
manière ce qui regroupe 250 corps de
métier et que nous prouverons que rien
aussi les couturiers également donc sont
également concernés et ça concerne
n'importe quel type d'entreprise c'est à
dire que ce soit des micro-entreprises
des entrepreneurs tout à fait à partir
du moment où c'est une entreprise quelle
qu'en soit son statut donc en effet
qu'elle soit en micro entreprises où
qu'elles soient je dirai davantage sur
une entreprise de droit commun sous
forme sociétale et bien à partir du
moment où elle est inscrite au
répertoire des métiers qu'elle est donc
déclarée auprès de la chambre de métiers
bien de ce fait là nous pouvons assurer
pleinement son suivi son démarrage
d'entreprise et son développement de
l'entreprise c'est ça parce que vous
accompagner
si on n'a pas encore créé l'entreprise à
partir du projet jusqu'à exactement
jusqu'à la transmission
on accompagne en effet c'est à dire
qu'on va travailler en amont de
l'immatriculation c'est à dire sur la
réflexion du projet que ce soit en
création ou en reprise
on m'a bien évidemment vérifier
l'adéquation projet en barre on va les
conseillers enfin il ya des stages qui
sont à des formations des stages qui
sont à faire quand on s'installe on va
faire une étude de marché on va faire
des appros chiffres et on va voir les
aides et puis ensuite quand je dirai
tout ce travail en amont est fait que la
personne est prête à franchir le pas
parce que si c'est ça d'une certaine
manière
eh bien elle procède à l'immatriculation
et une fois l'immatriculation fait et
bien techniquement va assurer le suivi
la jeune entreprise pour les premiers
pas du chef d'entreprise donc le but du
jeu c'est d'asseoir c'est de mettre en
place
administrativement son entreprise
socialement au niveau de son
organisation commercialement aussi c'est
pas sans incidence est donc plus présent
sur les trois premières années alors
emmener où il y un suivi qui est un peu
plus on va dire formalisé sur les trois
premières années c'est un suivi qui va
se dérouler en entreprise donc c'est du
conseil c'est de l'assistance sur les
thèmes que j'ai pu aborder ensuite on
peut être sûr du suivi je dirais un peu
plus périodiques ou là on est déjà un
petit peu plus on a lancé lancé où on
vient faire en effet je dirais une sorte
de diagnostic de l'entreprise ses points
forts ses points faibles et
préconisations voir si le chef
d'entreprise a bien intégré je dirais ce
nouvel environnement
ce que le mode enfin son fonctionnement
de ce que ça implique aussi d'être chef
d'entreprise donc et puis ensuite bien
évidemment de pouvoir assurer aussi le
développement au démarrage on construit
le socle est ensuite s'appuyer sur ce
club pour justement lui permettre de
prendre son arrêt à différents
dispositifs qui existent lesquels alors
deux exemples deux exemples donc nous
avons par exemple nacre qui est le
dispositif qui est un dispositif de
l'êta qui existe depuis un certain
nombre d'années c'est ce qu'on appelle
le nouvel accompagnement des créateurs
repreneurs d'entreprise qui permet de
bénéficier d'un accompagnement en amont
ni l'immatriculation et le suivi après
l'immatriculation est en autre exemple
nous
on est également labellisé donc auprès
de l'agefiph qui est un public je dirais
donc pour qui est reconnue au niveau de
la mdph handicap et donc de tous les
handicaps hinche d'airé et donc nous les
accompagnons et nous les suivons aussi
parce que il faut pas oublier que ce
sont également des créateurs
d'entreprises et ce sont des créateurs
qui réussissent également au niveau
d'une entreprise en parlant de réussite
quelques mots ça fait des années que
vous avez mise en place est ce que ça a
fait ses preuves au niveau de la
pérennité alors haut niveau la pérennité
oui c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est
sur des statistiques où on est à trois
ans sur un taux de pérennité à 83% qui
est inquiète un poteau il faut pas
oublier une chose c'est à dire que la
vie d'une entreprise souvent par les
trois premières années voire des cinq
premières années qui sont des étapes à
franchir
donc ils sont pas sans incidence d'où
tout l'intérêt de cet accompagnement là
de bien se faire accompagner parce que
voilà les chiffres leproux par la suite
et ensuite l'expérience aussi également
merci beaucoup d'être venu donc nous
présenter les différents dispositifs et
puis si vous êtes intéressé bien sûr
rapprochez vous des chambres des métiers